FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
sure you're going
to have a great experience.
Thanks for making it
all the way over here.
There's not much
history to this talk.
I just got extremely jealous of
Zack meeting Chris a while ago,
so I decided to reach out and
invited him over to Google.
He came.
He brought his friend
Ben over, and they're
going to tell you more
about what they do today.
CHRIS BURKARD: Just want to say
thanks so much for having us.
It's such a cool
experience to be
able to share what
we love to do.
I'll give you a little
bit of the background
on kind of myself and Ben
and sort of what, I guess,
culminated us being
able to be here.
We're also really lucky to have
a lot of the editorial staff
from "Surfer Magazine,"
Brendan Thomas,
the editor, as well as Grant
Ellis, the photo editor,
are going to be
joining us today.
They're a little
stuck in traffic.
And we also have Josh
Mulcoy, who's featured here.
This was the photo that was on
the cover of Surfer Magazine.
And I would say that for myself,
like 10 years of surf travel
to some of the coldest
places on earth,
this is pretty much
the culmination of all
these experiences and
what's made it incredibly
special and amazing is kind
of this moment right here.
So my name is Chris Burkard.
I'm a senior staff photographer
for "Surfer Magazine."
I've shot for Surfer for
about six years on staff
and I've been lucky
enough to travel
for them all around the world.
And a big part of what I
bring to the table for them
is really planning these larger
editorial style expeditions,
where it's not just
going to Mexico
for a swell or Tahiti
or something like that.
It's more about
getting a group of guys
together and trying to go
seek out somewhere that's
way off the grid, like
way, way off the grid.
And so these places, in our kind
of endless search for, I guess,
perfect waves or the
ultimate experience,
you could say has brought us to,
I mean me and Ben specifically,
to Iceland, Norway,
and Kamchatka,
Russia and South New Zealand
and Alaska and the Alutions
and Aleutians and pretty
much everywhere in between.
So I think for us,
when it comes to kind
of planning and executing
these experiences,
the coolest thing is
Google Earth actually
plays a huge role.
This place then we went to
the Aleutian Island chain,
it's basically one of the
most remote places on Earth.
It's like this island
chain that stretches
from Russia to Alaska.
And we'll kind of get
into that in a second,
and talk about some of
the details planning.
But just to kind of
give the back story,
it took about three
years to plan.
Would you say that's right?
BEN WEILAND: Yeah,
three to four years.
CHRIS BURKARD: From like
basically the inception
of like, clicking on Google
Earth and zooming in as far as
you can to see some little
whitewashed triangle of wave,
to actually being there.
It was just this long process.
And what we always find,
the hardest thing is access.
Because a big part of
what we're trying to do is
go to places where
there's no access.
There's six people living on
this island, all natives, one
white guy.
And basically no cars,
no roads, nothing.
You're basically on foot or on
horseback or on quad riding,
trying to find out how
to get these beaches.
So access plays a
huge part in that.
Let me just take you through it.
What was really cool was
that "Surfer Magazine"
did a big pretty awesome
tour with this film.
And for us, something that
me and Ben really like to do
is kind of make a
little more intimate
and create an experience
that's a little more
behind the scenes.
So that's why doing a slide
show has been super fun for us,
to come and talk about the
moments behind the film.
And I guess in a way
when you see the film,
it'll set you up for how rad
an experience it really is.
So this photo here,
this is basically
the view from our lodge.
This is-- what's the
mountain right there?
BEN WEILAND: The
mountain's called Vsevidof
there on the left.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah, and I
think that the little mountain
range is Recheshnoi, I think.
And It was so funny, because,
you know, like anyone else,
we're researching these places
and trying to look into them,
like, all we would see
is just like grey photos.
Like, sunny day
in the Aleutians,
there's just like foggy
skies, couldn't see anything.
We had no idea there
was even a volcano here
in this place, let
alone visible, actually.
So it was pretty ironic
to see this thing
from our view on some
of these clear mornings.
One of the things
that was crazy is
we kept, when we
were researching,
we kept getting coming across as
really ominous moniker, Cradle
of Storms, Cradle of Storms.
What is the Cradle
of Storms, right?
And what we realized is that,
basically, storms start here.
This is where some
of the biggest
swells and storms in
the world that pound
Hawaii and pound
California, and they
travel all way down
the coast and build
this long, long period.
And they just put perfect
surf in Santa Barbara.
When they're here, it's like
the most horrendous, crazy thing
you've ever seen
your entire life.
And you don't want to
be in the water at all.
But there's these
glimpses, these moments,
where basically the
storm is passing
or right before it
comes, where it just
creates this
momentary perfection.
And usually that
kind of culminates
inside some little bay
or some little nook,
where that swell can really
wrap inside of, and clean up,
and gather itself and stuff.
So that was really
cool to experience.
So, a lot of you are probably
familiar with Dutch Harbor.
It became pretty
well known, because
of the-- what's that show?
BEN WEILAND: "Deadliest Catch."
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah, "Deadliest
Catch" and some of those other,
I think, like, Alaska,
there's like an SOS show
about people saving,
getting saved in Alaska,
on helicopters.
It's based there.
So Dutch became really
well known because of that.
And all the other islands are
all very uninhabited, very,
very remote.
Where we were is
right, right here,
basically, in this little
island called Unmak Island.
I think at its peak,
it had about 60 people.
Nowadays, it's like six people.
And so, I think they were a
little nervous because we were
like a group of six, so if
there was a political vote,
we could have swayed the
majority in some way.
It was definitely-- there
was some blank stares,
and we'll get more into that.
But what really
draws us, I guess,
to these regions is
this, right here,
this big Aleutian
trench that you see.
And that big trench is what
really creates this opportunity
for massive waves, massive
waves to smash this coastline
and create opportunities
for incredible surf.
But with that, also comes some
of the most active volcanoes
in the world.
And actually right
where we were staying
was Mount Cleveland, which is
there, not my photo, stolen
from Google Earth,
thank you, is one
of the most active
volcanoes in the world.
So we would basically,
we'd wake up
in the morning, some of these
clear days, we'd look out
and we'd see these clouds kind
of looming over this volcano,
and we'd go to ask
Scott, who is kind
of our pseudo-guide for a
day or two, what's going on?
He's like, this is-- that
thing's erupting all the time.
I think it's actually the most
active volcano in the world.
But if you see this little
stretch of land right here,
This is actually
where our island was.
So it was super interesting
to wake up and see, and just
be in an area that's
so wild and so active.
And because of this,
the Ring of Fire,
which basically stretches from
South America all the way up
and through Japan
and everywhere.
It's one of the
places where you get
some of the best
surf in the world,
because of how those
tectonic plates,
and how all those big
steep drop-offs, you know,
submarine canyons create
opportunities for swells
to really culminate
on the coast.
Last year, just so
everybody knows,
Kamchatka is this big
peninsula right here in Russia.
So two years ago,
in 2012, me and Ben
did a trip there where
we flew to Kamchatka,
and basically drove around
in like a six wheeled
military vehicle and
explored for surf there.
So we know the region well.
This volcanic soil, it's like
amazing for building sand bars
and creating opportunities
for really good waves.
And I think that
we've always been
drawn to these areas
for some reason.
I don't know why
exactly, but we love it.
I think it that, this
little elbow up here,
for some reason, just that
little elbow where those two
plates meet, that's just
where all the activity really
happens.
So, I'm going to turn it
over to Ben, who's actually
going to speak a little
bit about Google Earth
and how much of a
role that's really
played for us and the
planning and, yeah--
BEN WEILAND: So Google Earth
is one of the big tools
that we used when we were
planning the whole trip ahead
of time.
It's just provides
a lot of inspiration
because we spend
hours just zooming
in on all these areas thinking,
like, man, what's there like,
it kind of makes your
imagination run wild.
And you're like,
man, I wonder what
it would be like to actually
walk along those beaches
and check it out.
So basically, there you can
see the Aleutian Arc and some
of the pinpoints that we put
down for places that we've
spotted and could
have potential waves.
So--
CHRIS BURKARD: We don't know
if, when we're researching
if it's just like a
pile of reef that's
sticking like 80
feet above the water
or if it's like a perfect wave.
We're kind of trying to use
our experience from other trips
we've gone on and places
that we've photographed
and stuff we've seen from the
air to kind of culminate that.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah, and so
here's a zoomed-in view
of the island we were on.
And you can see kind of
the volcanic activity.
You got the two volcanoes
there on the left
and then a huge crater
on the right and that
kind of makes up the island.
And then where we
were staying is
where all those
pins are located.
And so that's all just
possible locations
that we mapped out beforehand,
kind of thinking that's
potential areas that
we want to go to.
And like Chris said, one
of the biggest challenges
is just being able to
get down the coast.
And on an island
has no roads, you're
just trying to figure out how
realistic is it to actually
be able to get
down to the beach.
And one thing that was really
great about this island
is that you have the
Bering Sea on the north
and the North
Pacific on the south,
separated by three miles.
So you have a lot of
options to be checking out
weather systems that are
coming in from both directions.
And you can see there
Nikolski and the route
that we drove down every day
to the beach to check the surf,
so that's basically
here 3 and 1/2 miles.
So--
CHRIS BURKARD: I
think it was farther.
I think it was quite a
bit farther than that.
BEN WEILAND: So I don't know.
It's like, it's really one thing
to be looking at this on a map,
but then once you get
there, you realize how tough
it is to actually be able
to access these places.
And here's an example,
on the way back we
stopped in Dutch Harbor
and one of the pilots
was flying a mail
route and he invited
us to come along and check
out some of the islands
that he was flying over.
And so he actually flew
us around this island,
both sides of it.
And we've got to check
out some of the breaks
and just realize, when you
see the breaks from the air
and see the cliffs and the ocean
just surging up against it,
you realize it's one
thing to see on a map,
but it's a completely
different thing
to actually experience it.
CHRIS BURKARD: You've
got a question?
On the map.
Oh, so like, so good
left, good right.
BEN WEILAND: That would
be like a left breaking
wave or a right breaking wave.
So when you catch a wave, you'd
be either surfing to the left
or the right and so--
CHRIS BURKARD: Like,
we might see a cove,
and it might have like
a line of white wash
coming in on one side.
And we'd be like, OK,
that's a right hand, that's
a right handed wave, right?
So it's good for us to know.
Like, a lot of times
we're planning like,
what type of waves we're
going to be looking at.
It also really effects
who we bring with us.
You know, like, if
it looks like it's
all beach breaks
and super mellow
than we might pick a crew
that is a little more
versed in that.
But if it's all like waves
that break a mile and a half
out to sea and they're like
monstrous, maverick-style
waves, then we might pick
a little different people.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah.
CHRIS BURKARD: But one thing
I love is this right here,
you can see all these
different potential spots.
And this entire island
has surf, all across it.
But the only places
that we ended up really
surfing the entire time was
here, here, and here and here.
These four spots.
Never made it to this cove.
Never saw good waves over here.
It was like 80 feet and
like, "Victory at Sea,"
the scariest thing
I've ever seen.
All these waves
were just too windy.
It's incredible how little
we got to experience,
because we've barely
scraped the surface.
And that's one of the
things that keeps us going,
keeps us ticking,
and keeps us excited.
So I mean, and kind of
just the exciting thing
for being able to
know what's out there.
I've been to a lot of
places on the earth that
are just by 1,000 years
too early in terms
of like being well
groomed for waves.
Like Iceland, for example,
it's just, it's so raw.
And the Aleutians, they've--
I feel like, all the setups,
all the reefs, everything is
like perfectly established
for good waves, which
is really interesting.
So try to move forward
here, because I don't we
don't have tons of time.
But picking a crew is super
crucial to me and to Ben
when we're going on these trips.
And one of the things
that we always do
is we'll talk about in the film.
And it kind of sounds a
little serious and ominous,
but in reality, when
you're driving in
on a quad, every
day, 20, 30 miles,
checking different spots.
And you're at a beach
and on a location
where there's no
medic, there's nothing.
There's barely anybody
that speaks English.
And it's like-- nor anyone
that wants to speak to you,
you really have to be-- you put
your trust in these people's
hands.
So you're not just picking
folks who are kind of young kids
who you think are
going to be great
and you're going to
get great photos of,
it's more about you're
picking people who you trust
and who are your friends,
and who, you know,
if stuff hit the fan,
that you could trust them
and that they could
get your back.
So on of the people we
brought was Alex Gray.
And he's a total
lunatic, amazing person.
I'm glad he's not here because
we could poke fun at him.
But he's definitely like
the hero of this film,
just because of the
waves he surfed.
But he can surf anything
from two foot to 50 foot.
And the guy was
first in, last out,
really awesome person
to have on board.
And just a total character.
And then, Josh Mulcoy, who we
are able to have here today.
Josh is-- I've been able to
travel with him for years.
He actually has probably spent
more time in cold regions
than anyone else on
the entire planet.
He was like the first
person to surf in Alaska.
He got the keys to
the city in Yakutat
for opening up surfing
to the entire state.
So it's always cool
to travel with Josh
because of that knowledge
and that experience
he brings to the table.
He definitely knows how to
stay out in the cold and last.
And he always picks
the right wave,
as you can see from the
cover photo that he got.
He knows how to wait it out.
This was this little defunct
cabin we stayed for a day
while we waited out surf on
another part of the island.
Pete Devries, this
guy is incredible too.
He probably spends more time
in a wetsuit than anyone else
that I know.
He lives Tofino, British
Columbia in Canada.
And he basically is like
one of the best surfers who
was born and bred in cold water.
And the guy loves-- not afraid
of going fast, that's for sure.
So when you arrive
in these islands,
you know pretty immediately
that you're somewhere distant,
you're somewhere different.
We actually heard this
great piece of advice right
when we got there.
They said, there is an
absolutely gorgeous woman
behind every tree
on this island.
And we never saw a single tree
the entire time we were there.
So it was interesting
to be somewhere
that was like a proper tundra.
It's not just like, there's
some trees and it's like tundra.
This landscape is meant
to handle and work
with just the harshest
conditions you can throw at it.
BEN WEILAND: Because
you just have
wind blowing horizontally
at 90 miles an hour.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah, rain
does not come this way.
It comes like this.
BEN WEILAND: Anything that
sticks up from the ground
is going to be
flattened pretty soon.
CHRIS BURKARD: Including
houses and everything else.
So when this plane landed, and
we're unloading our surfboards
and they're loading reindeer
sheds and boxes of meat
that hunters have come back
from the island with their kill,
it was definitely a
unique experience.
They're looking at us.
We're looking at them.
We didn't really know
what was happening.
And pretty much,
they just told us,
just take your surfboards
out, throw them
down the middle of the plane,
which if anybody's ever
traveled with surfboards,
it's like the last thing you
want to do.
It's like fiberglass.
They're sensitive.
We're just shoving
them in the middle
and the whole plane's vibrating
and fiberglass is like flexing.
And we're like, this is
super great for a fire hazard
if we have to exit the plane.
But we got there in one piece.
You don't take a flight
here on a regular basis.
This a chartered, special
flight that they just
do every once in a while and
it's totally weather dependent.
So you have no idea whether
you're going to stay
and you're going to be able to
leave the day that you want,
or you're going
to be stuck there
for two weeks, which
totally happens.
In fact, while we
were there, they
had one run, that they
flew all the way from Dutch
over to this island,
and just couldn't
land because the
winds were too strong.
But as soon as we
got in the air,
we realized how-- I was
actually scared at first.
I was like, man, this is going
to be a barren wasteland.
This is going to be scary.
But as soon as we
got in the air,
we realized how beautiful
these islands were.
It was incredible to see the
water table in such an amazing,
one shot, just seeing it
from the snow, all the way
to these waterfalls
pouring into the ocean.
And we realized really quickly
that same idea, of like,
wow, this is going to be
challenging, the access
and what we're going to
be able to-- how we're
going to be able to
get to these spots.
Because we flew in on a day
when there was amazing waves.
It was actually
pumping, surf was just
pounding the coastline.
It was a beautiful day.
The sun was coming out.
And we knew immediately,
we were like,
wow, how are we
going to get there,
how are we going to
get from here to there.
Are we going to be able
to get there on quads?
Are we going to have
to hike or whatever?
So that's always kind of our
constant battle, I feel like.
And we realized
really quickly that
was going to be a huge one here.
And as we're flying in,
we're passing volcanoes.
We're passing
these amazing bays.
So, just for reference
too, over here
is right where we
were staying and we
would ride our quads to here.
And then this is the
bay that we surfed in.
And we never even got to
surf in this bay or this bay.
And it's kind of--
I look at this photo
and it hurts a little bit.
Because as we flew in, right
over this mountaintop or ridge
line, was this
perfect left wave just
peeling down this
point break, as good
as it gets anywhere
in the world.
And we saw that
thing and our jaws
dropped and we saw another
reef over here and another wave
here.
And we were just like,
how do we get there.
And we never even
got to go there.
So it's just like, the untapped
potential is so amazing.
And I think that's what inspired
us to go to these cold places
because there's no Starbucks
coffee on the beach or parking
meters.
So the Aleuts, the natives,
the natives are amazing.
They have such a
great sense of humor.
This plane-- basically,
they pulled this plane
right up to where
the landing strip is.
Because it had like,
basically crashed down
the way, or at the end
of the landing strip
and they just thought it
would be funny to bring it up.
So it's the first thing you see.
Another ominous
moniker for us as we're
already going into this.
And now, they just use
it for bullet practice.
BEN WEILAND: Well, it's
crazy, that culture, I guess,
has been on the island
for over 8,000 years.
So it was just crazy
to see that tradition,
like when they go
out and hunt, it's
like, they'll shoot
a seal or something
and bring it back for the
whole-- all the elders
and divide it up with all
the people in the town.
CHRIS BURKARD:
Yeah, I mean, they
would tell stories about
when they would cross the ice
bridge as kids and
stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Are they Inuit people?
CHRIS BURKARD: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Are the Inuit?
CHRIS BURKARD: They are Inuit.
BEN WEILAND: Aleut.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So interrelated.
CHRIS BURKARD: I
guess it's different.
It was pretty
interesting though.
It was definitely like,
they were closed off.
And then they got kind of
excited on what we were doing.
And they invited us over
for some festivities.
And it got pretty fun.
So one thing you
realize, we landed
and we just saw the
beauty of this place.
And my first impression
was like, man, this
is like-- we're seeing
all these homes, right?
And we're not seeing any people.
And it's just like
satellite dishes and homes,
and all these like
barricades for weather.
And it looked like
somewhere that you'd
get sent to have alien
testing done on yourself
or something like that, like
just kind of like something
a sci-fi novel.
And we just realized
everything was ravaged by wind.
Storms moved so fast
through this region.
In the film, when you
watch it, you'll see,
there would be sunny days where
it's offshore and beautiful
and we had t-shirts on.
And then literally 15 minutes
later, it would be hailing.
And some of those sessions, it
looked like totally different
days within the same half hour.
And so the storms, they
would just move through.
And they would be so
ferocious and fast and quick,
that it was really
an exercise in kind
of like being prepared and
living simply and understanding
that everything
you need is going
to be on this quad with you
for the day, everything.
And it was-- because I
mean you're going to a ways
out there.
And we would get flat tires.
We would get stuck.
We would fly over the
handlebars or almost get--
who knows what would happen.
So this is the town.
Like I said, it was
built to have 60 folks,
I think, at their
peak and now it's six.
So you have nice options of
like some geometric domes,
or a Russian Orthodox
Church, or I don't even know,
like barricaded fish homes.
That's basically your
options for living there.
But it was amazing
how they made it work.
It was beautiful.
And I think that, almost more
important that the weather,
it was really beautiful to
see how the animals interacted
with this landscape.
They completely own the place.
Like without a doubt, not
afraid of us, not at all.
Most of the animals are
brought there, horses, cows
and buffalo.
BEN WEILAND: Reindeer.
CHRIS BURKARD:
Reindeer, for military.
Because, in World War II, this
was a big military outpost
on the other side of the island.
So they brought all of these
cows to feed the troops.
Troops left, the cows didn't.
The cows were completely feral.
And they basically
owned the place.
I'm not even joking.
It's not like happy
cows from California.
These are like scary,
huge, massive cows.
Like we're taking a big
wide berth around them
because we don't want to
get anywhere near them.
Because the one thing
they told us, is like,
if anything is to charge you,
it's going to be the cows.
And they would look at us
and just like vibe us out.
Like, they didn't care
that we were there.
And we're used to
going to places
that are like-- as
surfers, you go to places
where there's local breaks and
you're kind of are respectful,
but this was like the
animals' local break.
They didn't want to see us.
They didn't care
that we were there.
They just completely
were so over us,
to the point where it was like
we knew that they were like,
just get out of
here, just beat it.
And every time
we'd go outside, we
would see another
element of that.
It was really funny to
the witness actually.
But like I said, the
reindeer, the way
that the animals interact with
the landscape is beautiful.
These are sheds that
were pulled off the road.
They weren't all kills.
There's actually tons of them
that just die everywhere.
So you pull them off so
you don't run over them
with your quad and
impale yourself.
Which can be a bummer, so.
So there's-- yeah, you'd
see just cow skulls.
You'd be driving-- or
something that would-- I
think at one point, we
saw like an animal that
was off the trail,
had just died.
And then a day later,
it was just bones.
But just the weather
and the animals
just come and just
take everything.
It was really interesting to
see that like circle of life
becoming really, really small.
So birds are a big reason
people go there as well.
The bird life is
actually beautiful.
I've never gotten
that close to an eagle
and felt like it was going
to attack me at chest height.
But they're amazing
all over the island.
And one of the coolest
things that I saw.
I included this photo
just because I loved it.
We were checking
out-- you can't really
see because of how
bright the screen is,
but there's this really
good right hander we surfed.
And then in the
foreground, there's
this fox, just
mowing on seaweed.
And I don't think he's
a vegetarian by choice,
but it was just really
interesting to see their habits
they've gained from
being in this climate.
So this is Alex holding up
one of the sheds for scale.
These things were massive.
I think that they
would say, I guess,
42 point sheds they would have,
just crazy, crazy antlers.
So Alex isn't here, so we can
pick on him, which is great.
Because I think you'll get an
idea for how much of a freak
he is in the movie.
But as time went
on, he definitely
embraced the culture and
the landscape the most.
I think it took its toll
on him a little bit,
to the point where, by the
end of the trip, it was like,
I think we all looked like
extras from a "Mad Max Beyond
Thunderdome" film or something,
just like totally feral,
like blending it
with the landscape.
I forgot to mention, but
the first day we got there,
all of our food was missing.
BEN WEILAND: Oh, yeah.
So we had to bring all of
our own food to the island.
And so, the day before we
left, out of Anchorage,
Chris and I had to load up four
shopping carts full of food.
And we were just trying to
jam to get it to the hanger.
CHRIS BURKARD: Going
shopping for six guys
on a high protein diet for
two week was super fun.
BEN WEILAND: And then when
we got to Dutch Harbor
on the plane, Chris
is like, oh my gosh,
I feel like the plane
should be fuller.
It's a small space
already and it
seems like we have more
space than I expected.
It turns out they forgot to
load half the food on our plane.
So we land there with like
CHRIS BURKARD: --noodles
and like ketchup
and all the things you don't
want to eat for two weeks.
So they gave us
seal and reindeer.
And we ate that for the
first couple of days.
And I mean, I'm all
for trying anything,
but that stuff gets old fast.
I mean, it's not
like good game meat
that gets mixed in
with some yummy fats.
Here it's just
straight reindeer.
is It was really intense.
But it was amazing.
It was cool to have that
instant kind of infiltration
of the culture.
So we realized pretty quickly
that quad travel was probably
our favorite way to explore.
It was amazing to
see this landscape
on four wheels like this.
And it was really such
a cool experience,
to be able to,
like I said before,
pare everything down
to just what you need.
And you can see, we've got
our axe, we've got our rope,
we've got our pump.
Because, at first, I think we
were kind of just excited like,
oh man, we're going
to be manly men.
We're going to go out there.
We're going to have everything
we need and look really cool.
And we're going
to film all of it.
But then, all of a
sudden, we realized
we need every single thing
we brought and then some.
Everything came into play.
And you can see how sunny it
is and how clean our clothes
are and this was like, the
first day, first afternoon.
But this is our commute.
Basically there's the town.
There's the town.
That's Mount
Cleveland right there.
You can kind of see.
I don't know if you can--
you probably actually
can't see it on this
screen, but you can on mine.
But it's like this right
here, it's kind of blown out,
anyway that was the commute
through this amazing grassland,
wetland area.
So this is Scott.
Any person who's
living on an island
with six natives
who's a white dude
is definitely running
from something.
So I don't put it past him.
He's an amazing
human being, but I'm
sure he's got some
kind of a sketchy past.
But he was amazing.
He guided us for the
first couple days.
And one of the
craziest experiences
was, we got to the end
of this beach, right?
And it was just this, you
know, they cliffed out,
and we're like, oh man, we
see a wave way over there.
And he's like, no sweat guys.
Let's just follow me.
I'll guide you through
the tide pools.
And so we actually took the
quads into the tide pools.
And I'm not talking like
tide pools like fun,
there's drop offs of like
15 feet on both sides
and we're driving on this little
tiny canyon with our wheels
like a foot and a
half underwater.
And he's like, go right at
this rock and go left here.
And we're trying to remember it.
And his dog's just
jumping around.
It was the sketchiest thing
I think we've ever done.
And he's like, by the
way, just don't do it
at high tide or low tide,
because then you'll get caught.
We're like , great, OK.
It was touch and go.
But Scott was amazing.
One of his claims to fame
was like, what was it?
Like he hadn't eaten meat in--
BEN WEILAND: Oh, in like,
20 years-- store-bought meat
in 20 years.
Because he just kills everything
himself on the island.
CHRIS BURKARD:
Anything, apparently.
So this is kind of
morning commute.
I love this photo.
You couldn't have even post
it if you tried, because these
are whale vertebrae and they're
just washed up on the shore.
And they're like so
incredibly heavy.
But it was just
amazing, like I said,
once again that circle of
life coming back to that,
and being able to see that
right in front of your eyes
as it's occurring.
BEN WEILAND: Front row parking.
CHRIS BURKARD: I'm not sure
if you can see the volcano
but that's Vsevidof.
And then that's
Recheshnoi right there.
So this is kind of the daily
commute, the surf check.
We'd come up on
these tall bluffs.
And we'd see over the
top of these hills
and be able to
check out the waves.
We'd be able to
see from here, this
is actually the right hander
that Josh got the cover on,
the one, the slide I
showed in the beginning.
And then over here, we can
look over and see this left
and then we could
see another wave.
So we have this
big expansive view,
be able to just pull
up on top, like king
of the mountain kind of thing.
It was such an incredible
way to explore.
But the rain did set in.
So we keep talking
how beautiful it was.
We have to remember, this
is the cradle of storms,
so it is definitely weather.
My absolute favorite
part in this film,
which I'm so stoked
for you guys to see.
There's a scene and I
want you to remember.
It's when we're sitting
inside the cabin.
You can just see the
windows vibrating, right?
There like-- it's looks like
a horror film type of thing,
where you don't even
know what's happening.
But literally we're sitting
inside this warm cabin
and the windows are vibrating
like 12 inches back and forth.
It was crazy.
You don't even want
to get next to them.
You're hearing this noise them.
And they're like double
paned glass windows
that are meant to basically take
80 to 100 mile an hour winds.
It was just unreal.
And so we sat through the storm.
And it was one of the
coolest things that we saw.
But definitely this
track, it changed
from being this epic, flat,
dry track to this muddy,
just getting stuck
every ten feet
track that was kind of brutal.
This is Ben.
He kind of got the worst
of it on a couple of goes.
I think one time we actually--
we did this half day
trip to go explore
these highlands.
And all of a sudden, like
we're like, OK, cool,
we're all taking off.
Later.
And I look back, and Ben's
not there, and I'm like,
oh I wonder, you had to
go get your back pack.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah, yeah.
I left my backpack like
two miles off the trail.
CHRIS BURKARD: It fell off
the quad from bouncing.
So that's something that
would happen always.
Like stuff would fly out.
And then your quad didn't start
and you got kind of stuck.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah.
So these guys just left me
because they just took off
and I'm here like
trying to start
my quad and nothing's happening.
I'm like oh my gosh.
I'm going to have to
hike five miles in
and there's a hail storm coming.
Finally it started up.
CHRIS BURKARD: It
was interesting
though because you'd
ride across these tracks,
and one day it would just be
super mellow, no big deal.
And all of a sudden
it would rain.
All this water would collect
and it would form a small river.
And you'd be riding along,
looking over at your friends
and smiling, and they'd
just endo, and almost
fly off the front of the thing.
It was kind of a-- and
you've got to be on your toes
constantly.
And this is Ben, just kidding.
Completely worked.
So this is Pete, another
time we got really,
really stuck, not just
partially stuck, I mean,
we're talking like,
you're going head first
into little pile of mud.
So we thought it would be smart,
given that Alex has the biggest
quad, we'd hook up the quads
and Alex would basically
pull him out.
And so that's what we did.
Alex jumped on, revved
it up, starting to go,
it started to pull
him out, I think
he looked back and stood
up, and all of a sudden
his quad started to
tip back, and all
I remember seeing
is Alex scrambling,
jumping off the
quad, surfboards are
like crunched on the ground,
fiberglass is flexing.
All I imagined was
like him getting
impaled by his fin or
something like that.
And just like the
trip being over.
But luckily that didn't happen.
I love this photo too.
I always look back at the
images think of the subtleties
because this one's great.
He's got his full wetsuit on.
And he didn't surf.
And that just shows how
bad the conditions were,
that we were like-- at
first we were like, great,
we're going to go down
to the beach, suit up,
it's going to be rad.
All of a sudden, after
four days of weather,
we're just like sitting
up at the cabin,
warm, suiting up
in full wet suits
because we never knew
what's going to happen.
Another thing, we had this
delusions of grandeur.
First day we were like,
ah, these little bridges
are so cool.
Let's film them.
These are rad, us going
over these little rivers.
And all of a sudden
it would rain,
and these things were mossy.
And you'd start to drive over
and your whole entire quad
would start to
slide off sideways.
So you have to hit
them going faster,
so you could kind
of plan your escape.
And we would just
slip off and you
could see the thing flexing.
It has like 85 boards on it.
And this is one of
the things that I
think made it hard to access
the other spots, right?
Was--
BEN WEILAND: The rivers.
Yeah, I mean there's
Ike bays all over
that we wanted to get to.
But there's just
rushing water and we
would have had to build our
own bridge to get there.
CHRIS BURKARD: We kind of
like brought the stuff,
but we're were just like-- we
would spend eight hours trying
to build a bridge to a
wave that might not exist.
That was definitely
tough, when you
knew there was such
good surf right there.
So this kind of the aftermath.
If you remember back to that
sunny, bright photo and he's
smiling and all happy.
And this is like
30 hours on a quad.
Your arms at the end of the
night, we'd be like this.
And you just couldn't
even move because you'd
have so much vibration
going through you,
that you'd just be so famished.
But mud head to toe, amazing
new Aleutian wax job right here.
It was intense,
to say the least.
So we definitely realized,
exploring this island by quad
was amazing.
The landscape, the
way it changed.
I've never seen anything
quite like it actually.
You'd come across
these bays where
there'd be just sand
dunes and these sand
sculptures out of
nowhere and then cliffs
that would drop off
for 100s of feet.
And then you come
into a little kind
of, almost like a
volcanic valley,
silt valley where it
would be black sand.
And they told us
stories of places
where there be like
beaches that would have
thermal activity
under the beach.
And you could dig away the
sand and create your hot tub.
We never got to that spot.
So next time.
But in terms of the
waves, the quads
were-- this was what
really made it amazing.
Being able to just
show up to these spots
and to see this incredible
perfect setups that would just
reel across these reefs.
As a photographer, being
able to zip around from spot
to spot and be able
to kind of cruise
over and explore these different
waves, and just get from one
mile to the beach to the other.
It was incredible.
This is probably one
of my favorite shots
from the trip too.
This is Josh about
to paddle out.
I think this is Alex, getting
the first wave of the sunrise.
We woke up super early
this day because we
knew it was going
to be clear and we
were so excited
to catch a glimpse
at clear skies in the Aleutians.
And it was frosty on the ground.
And there's birds flying around.
I don't know if you remember,
on my cover photo, one
of the feedback,
some of the feedback
that Grant gave me
actually was like, yeah,
people keep asking me if we
Photoshopped this bird in there
because it was like so
perfectly poised in the shot.
And you look back through
some of the photos
and you see these little
birds flying around everywhere
in this landscape, that
just would, I think,
trump anything else
that's going on.
And to us, I think,
that's what makes
these places so
exciting and amazing.
So this is the same day
too, just like I said.
Same session.
It had hailed.
It had rained.
The waves were still perfect.
And it just kind of
kept going forward.
So to we're wrapping
it up here, but I
couldn't leave without talking
about the surf a little bit.
The waves there were incredible.
I've never seen, I
think, anything like it
in terms of potential.
This was the first
day this little right
hander that we surfed.
And actually this
session, we got here--
BEN WEILAND: This
was the first day.
We had no idea this
was going to happen.
We kind of thought
the first day,
this was going to be
as good as it gets.
It was right before sunset.
CHRIS BURKARD: Guys
were like cracking
like celebratory beers.
And we're high-fiving and
we'd be like, we can go home.
We did it.
Like people are going
to be so excited.
Because when you
travel this far,
and sometimes if you
just get mediocre surf,
let alone great
surf, you're excited.
I mean, at least for us,
we're like, there's a story.
There's something.
So to get this wave that was
like an overhead barreling slab
that would be notable anywhere
in the world was amazing.
And it was in the middle
of the Aleutian Islands.
It was incredible.
Me and Josh actually,
on the flight over,
we're like, man, so many
trips, the first is the best.
Let's not blow it.
So we like literally,
just as soon as we landed,
we were on quads, didn't even
unpack, just went to the beach.
And we lucked out
and got this session.
The second day, we
showed up and we
saw this left a little
bit down the beach.
And we were like, oh,
wow, look at this set up.
This is perfect.
It was like ruler edge, which
means when the wave breaks
along a stretch of
reef that's so perfect,
it's like it was
drawn in with a ruler.
There's not a droplet
of water out of place.
And we were thinking, this
could be a really rippable wave.
And all of a sudden, as
time went on, the next day,
swell picked up,
the winds picked up,
it just became this
perfect barreling machine,
like something out of
Indonesia, like some reef.
I've never seen
anything quite like it.
This is one of my
favorite moments.
We never even surf this wave.
it was just another unnamed kind
of peek in the background.
But you can see our set up here.
Quads parked right in
front, these big headlands.
And I mean, in
terms of what we're
searching for, it doesn't get
any more perfect than that.
I love this clip.
I had to include in
there because Alex
actually holding a
GoPro in his mouth.
And I always kind of identify
like, oh, man, the waves
are really good if
you're like filming
GoPro barrels from the water.
And I never would've thought
that if somebody said, yeah,
you're going to go to Alaska
and get perfect draining tubes
and get these water clips
coming out of the wave.
It was crazy.
So I love this one because
he puts it in his mouth,
and just gets completely
tubed and comes out.
And the wave's like
kind of perfect.
But this wave is probably
the most special to me.
This photo, actually, I think,
resonates the whole experience.
I love-- you couldn't fake
this moment or pose it.
If you've ever
tried to, you know.
This is Pete walking
out through the seaweed
on the rocks, bowling
ball size rocks or bigger.
And as he's walking
out, he takes time
to look over and
see Alex getting
the first wave of the set.
And just like going off the
top, shredding this wave.
And there's Josh paddling
right back out to another set.
And there's an empty wave just
peeling off of the distance.
And not to mention, you
know, a volcano here,
which I don't know if you
guys to see the outline of it.
It's too bad because
this photo is
really beautiful with the
sky and this mountain range.
It's just everything we search
for, everything that we give up
everything to go for and
drain our bank accounts
and everything.
And so that kind of
led to this session,
which was so special to me,
being able to travel this far
and get a moment like
this and capture it.
In a way it was like
almost like hard to shoot,
because you're just so
enraptured by the beauty
of what's around you.
And a lot of people
have asked, oh,
is this three different
photos composited?
But it's actually not.
So kind of the icing on the
cake, what was this wave about?
BEN WEILAND: Yeah, so
this is, I think, halfway
through the trip, we were all
pretty much sick of the weather
and ready to head out.
And you know like,
man, shall we just
scrap it and try to
get a flight back.
And then we all
decided, we'll just
stay a little bit longer
and the very next day,
we came to this other
bay that we hadn't even
really looked at.
And at like 600
yards out to sea,
there's this boiling
wave that was
kind of just turning
on a reef out there.
And the guys say it and
just started flipping out
and wanted to give it a shot.
And I mean, it was just
like the scariest wave
that I'd ever seen.
CHRIS BURKARD: It's
cool because there's
that element of bringing
people you trust, you know.
It was kind of tough, because
we all want to surf this way.
We all want to go out there
and I'll want to shoot it.
And Alex wants to surf it.
And the guys want to go out.
But you also have to
weigh out the danger
versus the everything else.
And so it's tough because Alex
put his wetsuit on and paddled
out there, like two other days,
went out there and didn't surf.
This was basically--
this is a cool photo
because it shows how-- it
was about a half mile up sea.
You'd walk over this shallow,
shallow seaweed-covered reef.
Then you'd have to
basically paddle over
like really shallow reef
for another quarter mile.
And then it would get to
basically a sidewalk of reef .
Like, you can see the
reflection pool here and just
how flat that is.
It's basically like a big
massive Aleutian swell
that's pounding into
a sidewalk of reef
and just unloading flat.
So if you're anywhere
in this zone,
it's not where you want to be.
But when we go out
there and we take
those risks, and it's kind
of everybody's decision.
And so it was definitely
one of those moments
where it was like,
if he gets hurt,
our trips, everybody's
trip's over.
The last thing we want to
do is have to swim out there
and pull him out
of an orcas mouth
or like go out there and drag
his body in off of the reef.
Because we're like two days
from a proper hospital,
like for real, like, even
if the chopper can land,
or if a plane can land.
No medic, nothing.
So there's an element to making
that group decision that I
think is important here.
And it was awesome to
see this all unfold
and to see it be so good.
And this wave was incredible.
We were up on these cliff that
were 200, 300 feet high so we
could get a perspective over
because the whitewash was
so big on the inside.
And it was perfect.
I mean, in terms of good
waves, this as good as it gets.
And Alex kind of mentioned,
I think, he's like,
this is as good as back
door, which is basically
the other side of
Pipeline Hawaii,
or like some other waves
in Australia he's surfed.
It was so cool to see all
three of these guys trade
off barrels, just back to back
in some of the harshest, most
remote areas on the planet.
So this was like one of
the last days of the trip.
And for us to get this
experience was amazing.
There was actually
a period there
where Alex surfed by
himself like 45 minutes.
And I don't think he fell once.
But then when he did
fall, he felt pretty bad.
So everybody gets
a beating once.
It just happens.
I think Pete had a broken
board, had to swim in.
Alex got pretty worked.
And, yeah, but it was worth it.
I think, in summation, I think
with more than anything, me
and Ben, we know like
right off the bat,
that all we're really doing
is going out there and going
to these places and having fun.
You know, we're
not curing the sick
or giving water to
people who need it.
If anything, I think
what our goal always
is, is just to basically inspire
folks to want to get out there
and to seek more and to
cultivate and appreciation
for these wild places.
Because I think that's
what we've done.
And that's what
we've tried to do,
is go to places that hopefully
we can share with folks
and bring back these stories
and experiences and films
to inspire them.
So the next time they're
booking that flight
or they're going somewhere,
they're making that vacation,
to go a little farther, a
little more off the grid.
And have an experience
that is lasting.
And just push that scope so--
And I think we're going to
start the film right now,
but just to introduce
the film, Ben
was the guy that really
is the cinematographer
behind this entire project.
He is the guy who made
this thing happen.
And I was lucky enough to help
direct and DP this project
and the guys at
"Surfer Magazine"
made this thing
when what it was.
And the filming and the editing
and the music and Bryce,
who's not able to be here, was
the editor on this project,
did an amazing job.
And this, I'll talk
about it after.
That's it.
That's an interesting
one, actually.
That's such a unique thing
to kind of-- everywhere
you go, like if you go
to Iceland for example,
all the sand on the beaches
is like, volcanic soil.
So it's like microscopic.
And when the winds blow there,
which they do inevitably,
it goes places you
never even imagined.
So like you just can
have-- I've had lenses
get completely destroyed.
So it's just so much of it's
just kind of being prepared.
I think here, it was like
all about having dry bags.
And kind of being prepared
to get wet, preemptively.
So when that when it did--
And I usually have a lens
glass all over me.
I'll have like some Ziploc
bags and like rubber bands just
for those last minute
moments in your back pocket.
That always helps.
Then just having a good kit for
when you're back at the cabin,
to clean everything out.
Actually there's
one thing that's
kind of invaluable to me.
There's this product,
it's called a BC bag.
And it's like a aluminum
looking like bag
that has a bunch
of silica packets
in it that you could
put big electronics in.
And you basically
like-- in the past,
when I've gotten equipment wet,
phones, whatever, you put it
like rice or
something like that.
But that's really
not that great.
So this thing, you put in there
and you put it somewhere warm.
And it just absorbs
all the moisture.
They're really good.
I bring like three of
them and they're great.
Because at some
point, something will
get soaked, no matter what.
So that's--
Do you have any other tactics?
Just like blowing on stuff.
BEN WEILAND: No,
mean I just I built
like a little plastic
case for my camera
so that-- because you never know
if it's going to rain or hail
or what's going to happen.
So you just have to
be prepared for it.
AUDIENCE: What's the next
destination you plan?
CHRIS BURKARD: Ben
and I are actually
go to the Fair Islands
in October, which
is this small, really small
island, like super micro
in between Iceland and Scotland.
And it's just-- has a
really unique history.
It's like one of the only
islands in the world they still
whale really frequently.
And the culture's like the
closest to basically to--
BEN WEILAND: Like Nordic.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah,
Nordic, Norway, and Iceland.
Yeah, Norway,
because like Iceland
is like the second closest,
but they're actually
the purest bloodlines.
So it's like really unique,
really hard to access place,
but just some really
cool potential.
And a lot of awesome birds and
all that kind of cool stuff.
I think for us,
we're always looking
for places that are more like
visually beautiful as well.
So there's that, when people
see it and they engage with it,
you know.
Because I mean, by no means
are these the best waves
on the planet at all.
But we go there
for the experience,
which is just as important
or maybe more importantly.
I think it's that
satisfaction from looking
at something on Google or at
this little white triangle
or white speck of whatever.
And then going there and
seeing actually be real.
It's so important to us.
Anything else?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: First, thank
you for sharing this.
It was special.
CHRIS BURKARD: Thanks for
sitting through it all.
Sorry, I was long winded.
AUDIENCE: I feel like
I went on a vacation.
CHRIS BURKARD: And froze.
AUDIENCE: So my question is, how
do you actually manage access
to the land that
you have to go over.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah, so we signed
a permit while we were there
because the people
that live there,
they own that entire island.
And so, just when we landed,
we had to fill out a permit,
and pay for that
for the land use.
So you have a certain period of
time that you can be there for.
CHRIS BURKARD: Logistics
is just everything.
And that's kind of what, I
mean, it sounds ridiculous,
like, three years
to go somewhere?
Well, you only have two
months out of every year
that you would want to be there.
So we're always trying to make
it work within this two month
window.
And then basically, it
just didn't work one time,
didn't work the next time.
We were just running into access
issues and things like that.
And we finally kind
of made a breakthrough
and met a person who
was like, yeah, I
am a liaison for
the tribe and people
who want to come visit the
island, for hunters normally.
But he's like, yeah,
I can set you guys up.
And so that was kind of
our key to get in there
and make it happen.
It was cool.
They were really grateful,
happy to have us.
And we always try to be
super low footprint, which
is like a really important too.
Besides driving quads over their
native land, you know, so--
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So how cold
was the water on average
and what kind of
suits are we talking?
Like how thick of
suits do you use?
CHRIS BURKARD:
What do you think?
BEN WEILAND: Like
low 40s, like 41, 42.
CHRIS BURKARD:
Yeah, I think there
was some days-- it all really
depends on the wind too.
Like the water could
be a certain degree,
but if you're like, maybe
it's like howling, like 30,
40 knots too, it can
like, plummet the temps
outside a lot.
So it feels a lot colder.
I feel like some
days it would feel
like below-- like
high 30s, you know.
But it depends on if the
sun was out or something.
BEN WEILAND: And it snowed
while we were there.
CHRIS BURKARD: And some
mornings, it was icy.
That was kind of brutal.
Five mil wetsuits,
but more importantly
than the suit is your
gloves and your booties.
Seven mil.
Because like the blood leaves
your extremities first.
And that's really what
gets you really cold,
is when your hands and
your feet get cold.
So you're coming in,
you feel like you're
walking on wooden pegs.
You just have no sensation.
It's kind of brutal.
Getting warm before you
go in the water, I think,
is the most important thing.
We realized that pretty fast.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
or would you consider
submitting your film to
the Banff Film Festival?
BEN WEILAND: We
thought about it.
CHRIS BURKARD: We think we
missed this year's entry.
But I've actually--
we've submitted--
we've made another
film actually.
We brought it here.
It was filmed in Russia.
We made a film that trip
too and we submitted that
to a lot of mountain
film festivals.
And it's always cool actually.
I think me and Ben,
we really like,
we really like those mountain
towns, those communities.
I think we resonate with them
because we love cold places.
And so we actually showed this
film in Boulder and in Denver,
and two sold out places there.
And they loved it, which
was so cool to see.
They didn't quite
know like when to clap
when guys were
coming out of waves.
But they still got
the overall psych.
So it was really
cool to go there
and to share it with them.
But actually, we've
done, I've done,
some work with Banff
Mountain Film Fest and stuff
and had a photo submission
from these trips.
And there really
great people there.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, last
year was, I think
the winner was actually
a surfing movie.
CHRIS BURKARD: It was.
It was called
"North of the Sun."
It's this amazing film
about these guys who
went to Norway, this like remote
beach you have to hike into
and lived there
for like six months
and ate like-- I don't
even know what they ate,
it was like terrible.
It was gnarly.
They built a shelter.
It was really cool.
Was it was a really
inspiring film.
I'd recommend it
and check it out.
BEN WEILAND: If you like
films about people suffering.
AUDIENCE: Who
handles the logistics
for these kind of
trips that you guys do?
CHRIS BURKARD: Me
and this guy do.
It's usually like
emails and texts.
And then like we have a
couple-- as we get closer,
we have a couple of powwows.
For Russia, actually was funny,
because we have this footage.
For the Russia film we
made, we had this footage
from before the trip where
Ben was over at the house
and I'm talking to Lana, who
is like our handler there.
And she's like talking to us
about bears and bear traps
and how we were
going to get around.
And how we were going
to be protected.
It's always like the
same kind of-- you're
like talking to somebody.
And it's like the
connection's really bad.
You're getting like
bits of information.
And you never really
know until you get there.
There was definitely
some like shockers.
BEN WEILAND: You
never really know
who's going to be there on the
other end when you show up.
CHRIS BURKARD: You're
hoping like when you arrive
and the guys like--
BEN WEILAND: On this
trip, when we landed,
everybody there was so nice.
But then we heard like the
next island over, I guess,
the people that lived there were
pretty hostile to outsiders.
And we had no idea.
We could have landed
on that island
with like ten hostile people
who don't want us there.
We were just fortunate I guess.
CHRIS BURKARD: That
island's lame anyway.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How much direction
do you do for the athletes?
Like how much of it is like
they go out and do their thing
and you take pictures?
How much is it that you like
have ideas for the shots
that you want?
CHRIS BURKARD: I think
it's kind of a mixture.
It's like, it's cool because
usually we align ourselves
with athletes or guys who, they
know what we're looking for.
It's like we're going
to go surf this wave
with this volcano
in the background.
We all get it.
This thing's beautiful.
Let's do this.
But at the same time,
when they're in the water,
they're just doing their thing.
Like these guys are so
good at what they do,
that we couldn't even
direct them we tried.
Sometimes when, if we're
shooting in the water, which
this trip didn't really
allow, because I think
the landscapes were
so much better.
But typically when we're
shooting in the water
we'll be working really closely.
We'll be like trying to
get one particular shot
or line up in one area.
But with this, any of
the direction that really
came was more like, let's do a
couple of passes with the quad
here.
Let's do this.
Let's set up this shot.
It was all periphery
around the actual surfing.
I think for us,
we're just trying
to kind of tell the
story around that.
And sometimes that will take
a couple goes, but the surfing
element of it, it's just
like, whenever there's waves,
we're on it.
Because you can go to
these places and surf
like twice, maybe.
So we were lucky.
That was like I think
five sessions, six?
What, Josh, how many
sessions was the whole thing?
AUDIENCE: It was about six.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah,
like six times.
And I think like--
BEN WEILAND: Out of two weeks.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah,
out of two weeks.
Like long days.
So it's kind of brutal.
AUDIENCE: How did you guys
start working together?
CHRIS BURKARD: Ben
was stalking me.
And I just, you know, no-- I
was working for Surfer Magazine
and Ben was living with one
of the art directors there.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah and
he had reached out to me.
Ben runs this really awesome
like super funny blog called
Arctic Surf, and it was all
about like Arctic surfing,
like most places you'd
never even be able to go to.
And just kind of more
scientific perspective of it.
And so I had seen it and
he reached out to me.
And we kind of had this similar
interest and got breakfast
and became best
friends ever since.
No, I'm--
But we had similar
passions, wanted
to explore different
places and I
think our first trip was
New Zealand, the South
Island of New Zealand
in the winter,
which was really cool together.
Did you see it any
other different way?
BEN WEILAND: No, just
totally accurate.
AUDIENCE: When you guys
find a new wave, how long do
you kind of scope it out, or
is it like once it comes in,
everybody's tubing out there?
BEN WEILAND: That's a good one.
CHRIS BURKARD: Just kind
of depends, I guess.
It all the thing
if it's dangerous.
It's definitely like we're
not rushing out there.
We're like trying to get-- like
look at it from every angle.
Go up high, go low,
figured it out.
You know?
I
BEN WEILAND: Part of
it, like that last wave,
the really dangerous one?
It's like, it wasn't
even a question.
Like those guys
wanted to surf it
even though it was so dangerous.
So they were just
trying to get out
there as fast as they could.
CHRIS BURKARD: But
at the same time,
Alex went out there
those two days.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah,
and walked around
on the reef when there wasn't
any waves the day before
and kind of looked at it.
CHRIS BURKARD: Yeah.
It's a hard thing.
I think I almost
equate what we're
doing closer to mountaineering.
Where it's like
these guys want, they
want to get a first ascent.
They want to climb that peak.
And in a way, it's like, has
a similar like relevance,
because it's like there's
danger and there's
all these things
that equate to it.
But I think there's precautions
that you have to take.
And you have to be
smart and evaluate.
And you have to pick the right
board and the right fin set up.
And it's not so
much like it's super
scientific but at
the same time there's
a good amount of preparation
that goes into it so you don't
just-- Like when he took off
on that first wave out there,
I was like shooting, but
I was holding my breath.
I mean, if something
happened and he--
like Alex was the
only one out there.
Everybody else, we
were all sitting
inside waiting because we didn't
even think it was surfable.
He could have gone head first
into some urchin or something.
So we were lucky
that it didn't happen
and the session
ended how it did.
But it could have been
a film about-- The film
could have ended with us going
to the hospital just as easily.
Luckily that didn't happen.
Any other questions?
Yeah, shoot.
AUDIENCE: How much did
you guys get to surf?
CHRIS BURKARD: How much
did we-- Ben got to surf.
I did not get to surf.
That's always the toughest one.
I think because we invest so--
For me, at least this time.
For him, it's super
important because he
writes all these stories.
So like the article
in "Surfer," he wrote.
It's amazing.
And that's actually why me
and Ben joined up first,
because he's a
writer by a trade.
And cinematography kind
of came you second, right?
So, you've got to
get in the water
and it's important
for you to do that.
BEN WEILAND: Yeah.
But the same time, you're
thinking like, oh, man, this
is like a rare opportunity
that the waves are so good.
So it's like I need to
capture this as well.
So as much as you want to be
out there and experiencing it,
it's like you also
have to capture it,
because that window is so short.
AUDIENCE: Like these
guys are the first three
to ever surf certain
waves and then--
CHRIS BURKARD: For sure.
AUDIENCE: --you guys missed
out on it a little bit.
CHRIS BURKARD: I'm
like, I'm not even
going to worry about
getting in the water.
Like I just don't
even tempt myself
and don't bring that stuff.
And so usually if I am
going to get in the water,
it's like I'd rather
save my wetsuit
to be warm for when I have
to go swim, rather than be
cold and go and suffer
when I go back out.
You have to weigh it out.
Some days you're like, oh,
after they get in, I'll go out.
And then it starts raining.
And you're like, oh,
I'm going straight
to like my bed or something
like that or find shelter.
Cool, cool.
Thank you guys so much.
We really appreciate it.